joining me now Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green of the house
oversight committee congresswoman so the
reporting would be then if this were
true that the barisma scheme is
confirmed
then Trump is indicted I am sure it's
just a coincidence this all just
happened sheer coincidence finally we
get the information on on a legend
bribes of the Biden family through shell
corporations Etc
well I have to tell you Laura I feel
like we're winning and we won some today
when everyone feels like we're losing
especially with this indictment of
President Trump and this this document
hoax but what we read today in the skiff
and I wanted I want to let everyone know
this was an unclassified document this
is a document that all of America should
be able to see but the FBI is
stonewalling us and they would only let
us see it in a skiff well what I did
after reading the document is I made
notes when I walked out and I went to
the table and I wrote down everything
that I had just read so that I could
come out and tell the American people
what I read and it's exactly what you
and many others have been reporting for
so long and it's what everyone already
knew I followed articles of impeachment
on Joe Biden's Inauguration Day exactly
for this barisma pay to play schemes and
when he was vice president we now know
through the fd-1023 form that we read
today that Joe Biden was paid five
million dollars along with Hunter Biden
being paid five million dollars in order
to get Victor shoken fired so that he
would not be investigating Barista
anymore and Hunter Biden was working
very hard to get barisma to buy a U.S
oil and gas company and Hunter Biden was
promising that there would be a lot of
capital invested into this business deal
well when are we going to get those
redacted bank records uh congresswoman I
mean the redacted bank records of the
Biden the whole clan so we can finally
figure out how did the Biden family get
so rich wait that's just a simple
question that reporters don't want to
ask how did they become so wealthy with
Joe Biden in public service for decades
and decades how did it happen
well we have been investing
investigating that on the oversight
committee and I really have to apply the
oversight staff chairman Comer and all
of the members on the committee this is
this informant which is by the way the
FBI called this informant for this 1023
form their most credible paid FBI
informant and they they are trying to uh
make sure that we don't get our hands on
more but what we've been able to uncover
is we read over 2 000 pages of SARS
reports in the treasury Department and
those SARS reports are bank records
produced by Banks their their reports
they have to report them by law whenever
they see evidence of a crime or certain
types of wire transfers like a lot of
money from foreign countries and then on
our oversight committee we have
subpoenaed Banks and we've subpoenaed
bank records and so we have bank records
and we have evidence of wire transfers
from many different countries into shell
company llc's and then we have evidence
of payments out of the llc's directly to
multiple Biden family members but now we
also know that there isn't just one 1023
form that the FBI possesses there's
multiple 10 23 what and here's what yeah
there's more oh my god when are we gonna
when are we gonna get our hands on those
or are you going to get your hands on
those
next week and this is what this is why I
want to tell you in what seems like an
extremely dark day and where we are
appalled infuriated disgusted and and
just outraged over the hypocrisy of
Merrick Garland bringing charges and
Jack Smith bringing charges against
President Trump for this document hoax
and and you're right you it's today for
a reason on this 1023 form it references
two more 10 23 forms and so our
oversight committee was able to read the
first one today but next week chairman
Comer and of course uh Congressman
Raskin get to go in and look at two more
1023 forms and tomorrow subpoenas go out
for more Banks related to Ukraine uh
bank accounts and wire transfers so we
are moving along and I want to tell you
something really interesting the the
person reference their name is redacted
on his 1023 form the that we read today
said that it would take us 10 years 10
years to uncover all the bank accounts
and all the wire transfers involving the
bidens well on oversight we've done it
in less than six months and we really
think that we're on to a lot more but I
want to tell you this the evidence that
I read today Joe Biden should be
impeached this isn't this isn't even
something that should be disputed he
should be impeached and also prosecuted
this this is an Etch A Sketch of bank
records I could imagine I can only
imagine how many shell companies and
llc's and and Cayman Islands accounts
and everything are involved here but uh
we want to know where this goes and
where it leads and congresswoman we
appreciate you joining us tonight thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else